today's prime minister's questions was
not about answers
mr speaker it sounds like the comical
alley of the cost of living crisis
that would not have happened mr speaker
if we listened
to captain hindsight this must be the
oxford union debating skills we've been
hearing so much about everywhere you
look at labour administration it is a
bankrupt shambles
at the final parliamentary fracar before
the local elections party leaders each
made their last ditch pitch with labour
and the snp repeating their core
campaign messages on the cost of living
crisis
a vote for labor next week is a vote for
a very different set of persons instead
of converting a tory talking shop at
cabinet the prime minister should be
acting to help those children and help
families through the cost of living
emergency
in contrast boris johnson focused on
attacking labour's own record in local
and national government
never forget labor run britain in 2010
bankrupt because of what the labor
government did this guy is doomed to be
a permanent spectator mr speaker
they have they have no we have a plan to
fix the nhs and fix social care they
have no plan
now if you look at the language
kiyostama used today he was shamelessly
repeating his line that labor is the
party of working people and at the
bottom you can see tax and cost of
living featured a lot too
the words boris johnson used the most
were people
followed by labour a sure sign of his
strategy his approach that he believes
one of the best forms of defense is to
go on the attack
as today's session started news broke
that conservative whips are
investigating claims one of their own
mps was spotted watching pornography in
the commons chamber it feeds into a
wider debate about changing the culture
within the walls of westminster
especially after the controversial
angelarena leg crossing claims in the
mail on sunday the source of which was a
tory mp
i know the prime minister will have
whipped his back benches to scream and
shout
and that's fine
that's fine
but i hope i hope he's also sent a clear
message that there's no place
for sexism a misogyny i uh exchanged uh
messages with the right honourable lady
over the weekend and i i repeat what i
said to her there could be absolutely no
place uh for such behavior it was
striking that today kierstama was
flanked by women whilst boris johnson
was surrounded by men labor sources
suggest that was by accident rather than
design but allegations of sleeves in
politics seem unlikely to go away 56
members of this house are under
investigation for sexual misconduct and
that includes three of his cabinet
ministers so can he now confirm whether
he considers that sexual harassment
apparently unlike bullying and lying
is grounds for dismissal under the
ministerial code of course it's grounds
for dismissal
that was the final prime minister's
questions for three weeks it'll be back
after the local elections and the
queen's speech and the fortunes of all
the parties and their leaders may well
have changed by then